ich rufe auf den zusatzpunkt zwei
beratung des antrags der fraktion spd
bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp mit dem
titel sitzordnung im plenarsaal des
bundestages für die aussprache ist eine
dauer von 31 minuten beschlossen ich
eröffne die aussprache und jetzt muss
ich
die richtige reihenfolge nehmen so da
sind wir wieder rechtzeitig zurück denn
hier ist gerade aufgerufen die schon
angekündigte debatte zusatzpunkt 2 des
heutigen debatten tages sitzordnung im
plenarsaal des bundestages sie kennen
das ansinnen der fdp fraktion nicht mehr
weiter außen sitzen zu wollen also
direkt neben der hälfte ihr sondern in
die mitte zu rücken und da hat sich die
koalition insgesamt angeschlossen und
die begründung dazu jetzt von irene
mihalic
unglücklich dass wir jetzt diese debatte
in der sache führen müssen weil ich
erstens ehrlich gesagt davon ausgegangen
bin dass alle argumente zu diesem punkt
bereits ausgetauscht sind und zweitens
versuche mir vorzustellen wie eine
solche debatte auf die menschen in
unserem land wirkt angesichts der vielen
probleme die wir zu bewältigen
sie haben die wahl nicht an
wir als mitglieder des deutschen
bundestages müssen uns wirklich
multiplen problemlagen dringend mit
kraft und mit lösungsmitteln widmen ob
das die klimakrise ist auch dass die
pandemie ist oder auch die
terroristische bedrohung und führen wir
hier eine debatte zur sitzordnung um
denn aber ich will diese frage gar nicht
trivialisieren ja denn sie ist in diesem
konkreten fall für mindestens zwei
fraktionen hier im haus von sehr großer
bedeutung aber man sollte diese frage
auch nicht überhöhen meine damen und
herren die sitzordnung des deutschen
bundestages ist nicht in stein gemeißelt
sie folgt ganz grob der einordnung von
fraktionen im politischen
koordinatensystem
ganz grob aber mehr auch nicht und in
der mitte meine damen und herren und in
der mitte während sich ja dabei fast
jede partei und wenn wir uns die
sitzordnung in den landtagen anschauen
dann finden wir da auch kein
einheitliches system vor sondern so
ziemlich jede irgendwie denkbare
konstellation und ja es stimmt wir haben
die sitzordnung auf diese weise noch nie
geändert was aber nicht bedeutet dass
daran nie ein interesse gab und da steht
jede legislaturperiode für sich die fdp
wollte schon bei ihrem wiedereinzug in
den bundestag 2017 eine veränderung der
sitzordnung damals hat sich die cdu csu
durchgesetzt jetzt zu sagen das war doch
schon immer so ist natürlich
nachvollziehbar aber inhaltlich auch ein
denkbar schwaches argument meine damen
und herren für uns
für uns scheint der wunsch der fdp nach
einer veränderung
mindestens genauso nachvollziehbar wie
der wunsch der union alles so zu
belassen wie es jetzt ist daher zeigen
wir uns in dieser frage mit unserem
koalitionspartner
solidarisch und stimmt für die
veränderung der sitzordnung doch und das
lassen sie mich bitte noch sagen doch
wir appellieren auch an beide fraktionen
meine damen und herren in gegenseitigem
respekt und in anerkennung des
standpunktes des jeweils anderen im
laufe dieser wahlperiode einen dialog
über den zusammenhang politischer selbst
verordnung und sitzordnung zu führen
damit wir nicht in vier jahren wieder
hier stehen und die gleiche debatte
erneut führen muss und ganz herzlichen
dank
irene mihalic war das erste
parlamentarische geschäftsführerin der
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen es geht
um die sitzordnung hier im bundestag es
geht um den wunsch der fdp in die mitte
zu rücken und das würde bedeuten dass
die unionsfraktion ein bisschen aus dem
präsidium sicht nach rechts zu rücken
muss thorsten frei wird jetzt seine
sicht der dinge darlegen er ist jasmin
parlamentarische geschäftsführer der
unions-fraktion und gegen diese idee
sehr geehrte frau vize-präsidentin meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
frau doktor mit wenn sie hier von
respekt sprechen dann will ich ihnen
gleich sagen dass wir das verhalten der
koalitionsfraktionen als ausdruck von
respektlosigkeit empfinden nicht anders
kann man das nennen was sie hier
beantragt haben das meine ich in der
sache das meine ich aber auch in der
form sie haben hier einen antrag
vorgelegt der nicht einen einzigen satz
der begründung enthält keinen einzigen
satz und darüber hinaus
also wir haben ihnen diese debatte nicht
aufgedrängt wir haben ihnen vor allen
dingen diesen tagesordnungspunkt nicht
aufgedrängt aber dass sie hingehen und
diesen punkt vor weihnachten ohne
debatte still und heimlich durch den
bundestag zu treiben das ist wirklich
der gipfel der respektlosigkeit und das
lassen wir ihnen somit fürchtet da
werden die menschen nämlich sehen dass
das ganz offensichtlich die themen sind
und die probleme die für die
koalitionsfraktionen aktuell die
beherrschenden und die wichtigen sind
wir sehen das anders aber zu glauben
dass über die kalte küche zu machen das
lassen wir ihnen nicht durchgehen und
ich will ihnen aber auch nur sagen
sie haben wirklich nur wenige tage
gebraucht um den ersten wichtigen punkt
ihres eigenen koalitionsvertrages ad
acta zu legen da steht nämlich
geschrieben wir wollen den deutschen
bundestag wieder zum zentralen debatten
ort in der politik machen und das tun
sie eben gerade nicht der punkt geht
offensichtlich nur dann wenn die
debatten ihnen angenehm sind wenn sie
ihnen in ihren interessen entsprechen
und ansonsten halten sie sich nicht
daran ich will
ich will
an dieser stelle gerne folgendes sagen
es gibt im grunde genommen klar
durchsichtige parteipolitische gründe
warum sie das machen sie möchten uns von
unseren plätzen an den rand des plenums
drücken sie möchten einen monolithischen
regierungs block in der mitte statuieren
sie möchten für die mehrheit die
zentralen plätze hier im plenum haben
und es ist nicht in ordnung und liebe
auf die hallig
ich muss ihnen sagen es ist ja nicht nur
so dass seit mehr als 70 jahren die
sitzordnung im deutschen bundestag so
ist wie sie ist sondern wenn sie sich
erinnern an das jahr
1983 das sind die grünen in den
deutschen bundestag eingezogen und es
war die cdu csu fraktion die ihnen einen
zentralen platz zwischen spd und union
zugebilligt hat weil wir erkannt haben
dass es wichtig ist dass auch
mehrheitsfraktionen der minderheit einen
zentralen ort im parlament belassen das
ist auch eine frage der repräsentanz das
ist auch eine frage des
erscheinungsbildes des parlamentes und
deswegen
es ist für mich was sie hier tun ein
zeichen großer schwäche das muss ich
wirklich sagen es ist ein zeichen von
kleinkariertheit weil sie sich nicht um
die wesentlichen themen kümmern sondern
weil sie sich auf
nebenkriegsschauplätzen schummeln und
ich will ihnen eines sagen respektiv
ihnen bedenken sie das ende eigentlich
hat doch jeder hier in diesem grund die
erfahrung dass im parlamentarismus in
der demokratie jede mehrheit zur
minderheit und jede minderheit zur
mehrheit werden kann wenn sie das zur
disposition stellen wenn sie einen
solchen chor zur disposition stellen
dann müssen sie damit leben dass in
zukunft auch sie dorthin platziert
werden wo sie nicht hin möchten was
werden sie denn sagen wenn irgendwann
mal wenn irgendwann mal die afd zwischen
grünen und fdp platziert wird dann
möchte ich gerne mal ihre kommentare
hören ich bin sicher sie werden als
zauberlehrling enden weil sie die
geister die sie heute rufen nicht mehr
loswerden erlauben sie eine
zwischenfrage des abgeordneten dran
lacht
als ich gerne aber ich glaube das tut
jetzt wirklich nichts zur sache ich
möchte zu meiner schlussbemerkung kommen
das was ich eben angesprochen habe
bedenke das ende
es hat eine populäre vertreterin dieses
hauses frühzeitig erkannt deswegen
möchte ich gerne mit erlaubnis der frau
präsidentin gerne zitieren und zwar die
bundestags präsidentin bärbel bas die am
23 november in der berliner zeitung
folgendes gesagt hat das ist nur wenige
tage her ich rate den fraktionen fragen
wie die sitzordnung einvernehmlich zu
lösen der natürlich birgt dass konflikte
wenn man jetzt nicht einfach mit
mehrheit bestimmt dass eine fraktion
gegen ihren willen umziehen muss am ende
fangen wir nach jeder wahl an über die
sitzordnung zu streiten zitat ende
besser kann man es nicht sagen unser
ratschlag nehmen sie ihren antrag den
sie zurück in den ältestenrat ziehen sie
ihn zurück lernen sieht respekt
eigentlich ganz unwichtiger punkt den
tasten frei da macht normalerweise
werden solche sachen tatsächlich im
ältestenrat besprochen wir werfen einen
blick in den plenarsaal der hat im
moment die unionsfraktion am besten
mobilisiert auch die grünen sind nahezu
komplett in dieser debatte schon und so
nach und nach füllen sich jetzt auch die
reihen der spd-fraktion weil das wäre ja
ein ding wenn ihr am ende dieser debatte
die eine ampel koalition möglicherweise
nicht so präsent wäre wie nötig um für
diesen antrag eine mehrheit hier zu
bekommen also ganz schön viel los hier
im plenarsaal in diesen minuten zu einem
thema das wahrscheinlich nicht
entscheidend sein wird für die politik
der ampel koalition aber die
offensichtlich vielen abgeordneten sehr
sehr wichtig ist merken sie jetzt gerade
am rhythmischen applaus für die rede von
thorsten frei eigentlich sollte nämlich
jetzt beginnen johannes vogel
fischer geschäftsführer der fdp-fraktion
der kriegt jetzt auch viel applaus aber
natürlich aus seinem rein mal gucken wie
das hier weitergeht
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
regierungen die gibt es in jedem staat
aber parlamente die gibt es nur in
demokratie und deshalb sind
organisationsfragen des parlamentarismus
auch nicht egal liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und es wichtig dass wir hier im
plenum darüber sprechen und
dass sie ist diese woche sprechen
darüber sprechen das liegt ja in der
natur der sache denn um zu funktionieren
muss sich ein parlament konstituieren
und das tun wir diese woche mit der
konstituierung der ausschüsse und
deshalb ist es doch auch klar dass wir
wenn wir von der vorläufigen zur
dauerhaften ordnung dieses bundestages
für diese legislatur übergehen dass wir
die frage der sitzordnung ein für alle
mal entscheiden diese woche liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der union
und das ist richtig und
wir erklären erklären diese frage allein
deshalb ausnahmsweise nicht im
ältestenrat sondern hier im plenum weil
sie nicht mit sich haben reden lassen
diese frage kommt doch wahrlich nicht
überraschend wir haben sie aufgebracht
2017 als wir erstmalig in den bundestag
als ein neuer tfg bett zurückgekehrt
sind sie wollten nicht mit sich reden
lassen sie war gegenstand im vor
ältestenrat liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
sie war gegenstand von medialen debatten
sie war gegenstand des allerersten
interviews dass thorsten frei als
kollege erster pdf und ich gemeinsam
hier gegeben haben jetzt tun sie doch
nicht so als würde hier ein
hau-ruck-verfahren erfolgen die kollegin
des schalls gesagt die argumente sind
ausgetauscht wir müssen entscheiden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von der
union und das haben wir heute
worum es geht ist eine ganz einfache
frage nämlich das links-rechts-schema
der politik dass es wahrlich nicht
perfekt aber das links-rechts-schema der
politik ist ganz offenkundig dass
nachdem dieser deutsche bundestag bei
seinen fraktionen mit einer ausnahme
sortiert ist jeder kann das sehen jede
besucherin jeder besucher der hier die
im plenarsaal erklärt bekommt versteht
das und sieht dass jede schülerin die
über den bundestag in der schule lernt
versteht dass es gibt nur eine einzige
anomalie nämlich dass die freien
demokraten nicht in der mitte sitzen
denn wir sind eine kraft der politischen
mitte und deshalb gehören wir auch in
die mitte des plenums liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen von der union
so war und ist es in der klaren mehrheit
der parlamente weltweit so ist es
übrigens auch in ganz vielen landtagen
in schleswig holstein in hamburg in
niedersachsen in rheinland pfalz im
traditionsreichen baden württemberg so
war es übrigens
2018 bis 2018 auch in hessen da saßen
die freien demokraten traditionell in
der mitte des plenums bis ja bis volker
bouffier mit seiner mehrheit entschieden
hat dass die freien demokraten gegen
ihren willen rechts von der union
gesetzt werden liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen so war es übrigens auch in
bayern da saßen die freien demokraten
immer in der mitte des maximilianeums
wenn sie dem parlament angehört haben
bis 2018 wo die csu mit ihrer mehrheit
entschieden hat dass die freien
demokraten gegen ihren willen nach
rechts gerückt werden sind sie doch
nicht von arroganz der macht oder
respektloses wenn sie das selber in
hessen und bayern machen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der union
und liegen lassen wir uns da nichts zur
arroganz der macht erzählt wahrlich
nicht
und kommen sie mir auch nicht bitte mit
das war schon immer so dass er das
argument was angeführt wurde in der
paulskirche in ersten gewählten
parlament auf bundesebene demokratisch
da waren die fraktionen von links nach
rechts nach politischen spektrum
sortiert und so saßen die liberalen
gruppen in der mitte in weimar da saß
die ddp die partei von walther rathenau
nachdem heute unser fraktionssaal
benannt ist die partei von friedrich
naumann nachdem unsere partei stiftung
benannt ist die partei von ersten
bundespräsidenten theodor heuss saß in
der mitte und rechts von ihr das zentrum
eindeutig ihre vorgängerpartei es war
nicht immer so liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen sondern die freien demokraten
den liberalen gehören diesem land in die
mitte auch im plenum liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen von der union
natürlich ist die mitte vielfältig wir
repräsentieren sie nicht allein ist auch
gut so deswegen sind wir als
demokratische parteien der mitte
koalitionsfähig aber es kann doch kein
zweifel bestehen dass spd und grüne sich
als mitte-links-parteien begreifen und
es kann doch auch kein zweifel bestehen
dass sie sich auch als konservativ
begreifen also als mitte-rechts-parteien
liebe kolleginnen kollegen von der union
liberalismus das ist die verbindung von
wirtschaftlicher und gesellschaftlicher
freiheit ich bin stolz drauf dass der
präsident von gesamtmetall den
koalitionsvertrag den aktuellen lobt als
besser den an dem sie beteiligt waren
diebe kolleginnen kollegen von der union
ich bin stolz darauf dass wir für
marktwirtschaft stehen und für gegen
steuererhöhungen aber ich sage ihnen
auch ich bin auch stolz darauf dass wir
für gesellschaftliche freiheit stehen
diese koalition die
liberalisiert das web und die
reproduktionsmedizin die verband die
vorratsdatenspeicherung aus dem gesetz
die modernisiert das
staatsbürgerschaftsrecht die schafft
verantwortungs gemeinschaften und für
all diese vorhaben wird diese koalition
von rechts von ihnen kritisiert dass es
doch auch die wahrheit in der tradition
zustand den wir abwägen müssen in diesen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich respektiere das weil diese breite
des demokratischen spektrums und der
meinungsstreit hier zu unserer
demokratie dazugehört aber das macht
doch deutlich dass das nachvollziehbare
anliegen das plenum hiernach lieblings
rechts spektrum nach dem politischen
spektrum zu sortieren dass sich das
gegen niemanden richtet sie selber
informieren diese koalition ja nicht als
links rechts sondern als links gelb und
die csu beispielsweise hat gerade ihr
mitgliedermagazin ein fiktives interview
mit franz josef strauß abgedruckt auf
vier seiten hat das mit interesse
gelesen weil franz josef strauß der hat
mal gesagt rechts von der union soll es
keine demokratische partei geben die
unzweifelhaft auf dem boden der
verfassung steht
20.000 seinen willen haben nur polen
denn dafür sorgen die hier im deutschen
bundestag
es gibt
es gibt kein historisch schlüssiges
argument gegen die sitzordnung die wir
heute hier beschließen wollen es gibt
auch kein sachlich schlüssiges argument
liebe kollegen von der union es gibt
einfach nur dass das zuletzt so war es
gibt einfach nur ein bisschen gewohnheit
ich verstehe dass aus konservativer
perspektive man etwas nicht verändert
will an dass man gewohnt ist wir sind
ehrlich gesagt andere auffassung
wir sind der auffassung man verändert
etwas wenn es dafür einen vernünftigen
grund gibt deshalb beschließen wir das
heute unter nach streiten da werde über
die sache vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
die johannes vogel erst hat mir ein
parlamentarischer geschäftsführer der
fdp-fraktion hat unter anderem ein
interview erwähnt dass er gemeinsam
gegeben hat mit thorsten frei in der
vergangenen woche war das und jetzt
raten sie mal bei welchem kleinen
tapferen sender das stattgefunden hat
der bundestag diskutiert weiter über die
sitzordnung hier im plenarsaal und da
ist auf der rednerliste jetzt vorgesehen
stefan renner aus der fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
welch unwürdiges schauspiel ich hoffe
wirklich dass viele millionen menschen
draußen mal schauen was hier in diesem
bundestag los ist zu welchem
kasperletheater sie diesen bundestag
haben verkommen lassen heute morgen
sollte über einen 60 milliarden
nachtragshaushalt 30 minuten debattiert
wurde werden wir sind dann gott sei dank
eingeschritten dann wurden 60 minuten
raus normalerweise wird über
auslandseinsätze der bundeswehr wo es um
leben und tod um soldaten geht 30
minuten debattiert und das machen wir
jetzt wieder passiert 30 minuten lang
war die weil ihr nicht nebeneinander
sitzen wollte weil der der sitzplan
durcheinander geredet ist ja wie krank
ist denn sowas wichtige debatten gehören
ins haus und nicht so ein
kasperletheater wer neben wem sitzt du
nicht nimmt vorweg und ist sowieso
vorstellen neben uns sitzt wir sitzen
sowieso demnächst überall von daher ist
es das ganz egal fast pragmatisch aber
wenn ihnen das so wichtig ist und ich
kündige das für die fraktion an wenn
ihnen das so wichtig ist dann können wir
gerne am ende der debatte die
namentliche abstimmungen darüber machen
und mal sehen wer sich namen nicht wie
positioniert sich bitte dass sie den
park egf aufzunehmen meine damen und
herren
736 abgeordnete maler halbe stunde
ungefähr 380 man stunden die wir jetzt
darauf verschwenden dass die hellbraune
koalition wenn man rot und grün vermengt
und bisschen gelb das für mich kommt der
herr braun raus dass die hellbraune
koalition entwirrte die sitzordnung hier
ändern möchte sollen sie tun wir haben
nichts dagegen
die cdu kann sich gern neben uns setzen
sie kann viel lernen wie geht gute
oppositionsarbeit das ist bei uns zu
lernen wie geht vor allem
korruptionsfreie politische arbeit das
kann man von uns lernen und zu langsamen
liebe cdu verbindet uns ja auch dass es
uns glücklich gemacht dass merkel weg
ist oder das sehe ich ihnen anders wir
werden glaube ich auch eine gute
nachbarschaft hier hinarbeiten und sind
im endeffekt sehr sehr froh darüber
insofern könnte man meinen dass wir als
afd
richtig geschickt vorgegangen sind denn
wir wollen neben diesen blasierten typen
von der fdp uni wir sitzen es ist
unerträglich was in dieser fraktion in
letzter zeit brooks ist je näher die
sich so an die macht heranrückten desto
blasierter wurde diese machtversessene
macht vergessene
grün-links devote posten grapscher
truppe von der fdp ekelhaft was aus
dieser partei geworden ist von uns auf
die linke seite am besten so weit weg
wie möglich von und apropos posten
grapscher auch was an sexistischen
sprüchen und an machen aus der fdp druck
bekommen das werden sie dir vor den
grünen demnächst erleben wir haben
graumelierte freiheitskämpfer der fdp
die robben sich schamlos an die afg
abgeordneten heran der
fraktionsvorsitzende berichteten wir von
lüsternen blicken einer
verteidigungspolitische sprecherin der
fdp der er fühlt sich sexuell belästigt
es ist eine katastrophe was da die
höheren sprüche
zu hören spur gesperrt die afd ins lager
sie hören sprüche ihr kommt zu viel aus
dem ausland das ist eine verkommene
gurkentruppe geworden wir wünschen uns
wirklich dass die so weit weg von uns
sitzen die möglich und freuen uns auf
eine gute nachbarschaft zur
cdu/csu im sinne einer guten
konstruktiven oppositionsarbeit für
lacke
stefan brändle aus der fdp-fraktion
was soll man sagen wir geben rüber in
die bundespressekonferenz nicht weit von
ihr denn da gibt es die wöchentliche in
den letzten monaten und jahren
jedenfalls wöchentlich immer
stattgefunden haben der pressekonferenz
des bundesgesundheitsministers mit dem
präsidenten des robert-koch-instituts
der bundesgesundheitsminister hat
gewechselt die pressekonferenz bleibt
ich gebe rüber in die
bundespressekonferenz
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen ich kann
verstehen dass wir hier eine debatte
führen wer sitzt künftig neben der hfc
im deutschen bundestag weil das ist das
eigentliche thema über das wir reden und
ich verstehe jeden hier ein haus der
sich schämt neben ihnen zu sitzen
und weil weil wir sind menschen gefallen
sind will ich noch mal sagen worum es
geht natürlich hat der kollege frei
damit recht dass man dinge
einvernehmlich im ältestenrat klärt nur
dieses thema ist nicht einvernehmlich im
ältestenrat zu klären und deshalb muss
es dorthin wo es geklärt werden kann in
das parlament im deutschen bundestag und
deshalb wird es ja heute entschieden
herr kollege frei
und wieso haben wir dieses thema ohne
debatte aufgesetzt weil wir finden es
muss entschieden werden aber wir
brauchen auch keine lange debatte dazu
die bürgerinnen und bürger da draußen
sie erwarten von uns dass wir aber die
pandemie bekämpfung sprechen die
erwarten von uns dass wir ihn antworten
geben wie wir arbeitsplätze sichern in
dieser transformation die erwarten von
uns wie wir die klimakrise bekämpfen die
demographie und die globalisierung
deshalb haben wir das ohne debatte
aufgesetzt es ist ihr gutes recht von
dem haben sie gebrauch gemacht debatte
aufzusetzen der stellen wir uns auch
hier mit an dieser stelle und lassen sie
mich zum schluss kommen sagen wir haben
gestern die regierungserklärung vom
kanzler der ampel gab von bundeskanzler
olaf scholz er hat viele antworten auf
die fragen der bürgerinnen und bürger
gegeben und für uns alle ist klar wir
sind eine koalition der mitte und
deshalb stimmen wir heute als spd auf
der veränderung dieser sites ordnung zu
ich grüße sie herzlich von hier aus und
gebe das wort dem kollegen jan korte von
der fraktion die linke
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
das glaube ich mir bis jetzt die beste
debatte die wir in dieser
legislaturperiode hier hatten wirklich
mal voraussagen kann es fällt doch ein
wenig auf und da möchte ich was zu sagen
kollege frei ich finde das schon relativ
bemerkenswert dass sie ja mal sagen wie
sie und ihre fraktion 30 jahren mit
meiner partei damals der pds und dann
der linksfraktion umgegangen sind und
sich jetzt hier hinstellen weil es jetzt
ihnen einmal hier an den kragen geht
diese weinerlichkeit das ist wirklich
sehr traurig sagt ist einen politischen
deal sondersgleichen ich wollte gute
gründe warum müssen wir uns heute mit
dieser zunächst auf den ersten blick
mittel wichtigen frage überhaupt
beschäftigen zunächst einmal sagt etwas
dieser antrag aus dass überhaupt
gestellt werden muss über die braune
kasper truppen dort schon das ja das
eigentliche sind das heißt nämlich aus
sie an der plakatiert deutschland aber
normal war glaube ich ihr slogan und ich
kann hier zumindest mal für die
demokratischen abgeordneten feststellen
jeder normale abgeordnete möchte nicht
neben ihm sitzen das erst wenn die
sachlage nicht sehr viel zu tun haben
das bild
so sieht hier mal auf
und das auch mal in aller klarheit zu
sagen warum sollte die union und meine
fraktion die linke findet die
verfahrensrechte etwas unglücklich
gewählt wurde aber wir tragen das
inhaltlich mit warum ich möchte es
begründen zunächst einmal gibt es das
links-rechts-schema seit der großen
französischen revolution und deswegen
hat das einen bestimmten grund und ist
auch sehr sinnvoll denn auch wir als
linke halten daran fest dass wir die
politik anordnung analysieren müssen
anhand des links rechts schema hast
dabei bleiben wir und das hat auch sehr
gute gründe aus historischer
verantwortung jetzt will ich aber auch
politisch aktuelle gründe dafür anführen
warum sie dort hinten müssen und sie
dorthin müssen da will ich sagen gestern
bei der rede ihres fraktionsvorsitzenden
ralph brinkhaus es hört ja nicht auf bei
ihnen ja und da müssen sie kommen
kollege frei sie haben gesagt bedenke
das ende also das ist erstmal etwas das
haben sie so wie sie mit uns umgegangen
sind nicht bedacht dass sie ihn sie dann
jetzt heute das ist aber eine andere
frage ich will also noch mal was sagen
ich finde ist auch tagespolitische
aktuell machen ralph brinkhaus sagte
gestern an dieser stelle zum
wiederholten male die das die ganze zeit
tun dass sie weder mit der fdp noch mit
der linken etwas zu tun haben wollen
also diese gleichsetzung von links und
rechts das eine tradition von rechts
reaktionäre geschichtsschreibung für die
insbesondere ernst leute steht und wer
so rum spets darf sich nicht wundern
dass er dann weiter nach rechts gesetzt
das ist nach lage hier
lesen wird unterschätzt nur dann will
ich dem 2 zum zweiten noch einen
inhaltlichen grund geben sie haben
insbesondere den letzten jahr die afg
stark gemacht weil sie die ganze zeit
für seine kollegen dobrindt ist ja
gerade anwesend söder hat dass dort bis
vor zwei jahre macht dann hat er was
ganz anderes gemacht haben sie das zeug
nachgeplappert insbesondere zum bereich
der migration und haben die tritte lasst
uns stark gemacht auch das ist ein grund
dafür dass sie weiter rechts sitzen
müssen das ist denn die theoretische
holen dann will ich immer mal sagen ich
habe ein paar preise in sachsen anhalt
als ich glaube die haben in sachsen
anhalt überhaupt irgendein ostdeutschen
landesverbänden der cdu hat doch mal ein
fettes problem denn die tür zu den nazis
ist bei ihnen dort nicht zu die
sperrangelweit offen das müssen nach
höchste stand das war die lage in der
hütte und ab jetzt unter für nicht ja
und der politik natürlich ein
politischer prozess ich würde schon
sagen also bei der fdp nach der gründung
der bundesrepublik wäre doch wirklich
falsch gewesen wenn sie dort gesessen
hätten dann gehörten sie in der tat an
den rechten rand das muss man es sagen
es gab eine zeit da
148 da gab es den alliierten
hochkommissar mcleod er hat mir überlegt
ob er denn der weg verband der fdp mann
verhaftet weil er das halbe 30 als
hauptband und herum hinüber zeit aber
kann er feststellen dass ich da sehr
viel geändert hat und deswegen finde ich
das eine legitime forderung um eine
fraktion wird das heute hier
unterstützen ich kann abschließend sagen
für uns als fraktion die linke leider
gottes etwas kleiner geworden aber ich
kann eines feststellen wir sind stolz
und sitzen gerne hier ganz links außen
denn weltweit sitzen dort in den
parlamenten diejenigen kräfte die schon
immer für eine idee der freiheit und
gleichheit am konsequentesten gekämpft
haben und deswegen sind wir ganz in
ordnung mit der sektor unterstützen
elantra vielen dank
das wort für die cdu/csu faktoren hat
der kollege patrick schnieder
auch präsidentin liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen
wenn ich mir die beiträge der
koalitionsfraktionen hier vor augen
führe fühle ich mich erinnert an die
regierungserklärung von gestern die
tagesschau hat dazu gesagt viel geredet
wenig gesagt
inhaltlich haben sich überhaupt kein
argument für das ansinnen geliefert
gesetz ordnung heute zu ende
sie haben in der sache im vorfeld dieser
debatte einen grund genannt und heute
hat die linke ihren sekundiert ihnen von
der fdp sekundiert sie wollen nicht
neben der afg sitzen das ist ja nun
wirklich ein kindergarten argument aber
im übrigen gilt das für alle fraktionen
hier das gilt vielleicht für eine
fraktion das was herr korte gerade
gesagt hat würde ihn dazu prädestiniert
den platz neben der neben den rechten
hier in parlament eingelegt
sie haben ihrem handrad und ich hätte
auf die fdp zurück alleine damit
begründet dass sie über 200 jahre
parlamentarische tradition hier
referiert haben und sind wir dabei
feststellen dass die fdp mal mehr oder
weniger rechts gesessen hat mal mehr
oder weniger der mitte gesessen hat dann
sagt das nur eines außen politische
beliebigkeit wenn sie in diesem schema
rechts links weiter senken
und eines kann ich ihnen nicht ersparen
und das merkt man ja bei den
redebeiträgen ihrer koalitionspartner
das sieht man auch an den redezeiten die
verteilt worden denn ist das doch
eigentlich darüber zu reden und sie
müssen uns auch nicht den vorwurf machen
dass wir hier eine debatte führen sie
haben das thema aufgemacht als gäbe es
nichts wichtig aus in diesem lande als
die sitzordnung deutschen bundestag
verändern
und dann ist dieses verfahren an
intransparenz ja nicht zu überbieten
auch das müssen sie sich mal hinter die
ohren schreiben
gestern ist der antrag eingegangen dass
man als ohne debatten punkt heute über
diese frage reden es ist es ist im
normalfall so das ist parlamentarische
tradition dass wir über fragen die das
parlament als ganzes betreffen im
ältestenrat reden aber nicht im
verborgenen und geheim und ohne
aussprache und deshalb haben wir zu
recht dass heute hier als debatte
aufgesetzt und zu zeigen wie sie mit
diesem parlament umgehen und auch das
erinnert mich oft das erinnert mich an
die an die regierungserklärung von
gestern da hat der bundeskanzler gefühlt
in jedem zweiten satz abgewechselt
zwischen den worten respekt und neuer
stil wenn das der neue stil ist haben
und sagen es ein schlechter stil sehen
sie hier praktizieren
und ich kann nur betonen ist an
respektlosigkeit nicht zu überbieten so
mit der opposition um zu gehen denn der
einzige grund warum sie die sitzordnung
ändern wollen ist der dass sie sich als
koalition prominent in die mitte des
parlament sitzen wollen die opposition
an den rand drängen wollen das ist
schlechter stil das ist wenn diese
möglichkeit und deshalb mathurin
verfahren auch nicht gut gehe
so
damit
damit schließt sich die aussprache
geklatscht werden darf natürlich auch
nachdem die aussprache geschlossen ist
und ich komme zur abstimmung über den
antrag der fraktion der spd bündnis
90/die grünen und fdp auch drucksache
268 mit dem titel sitzordnung im
plenarsaal des bundestages er stimmt für
diesen antrag
wer stimmt dagegen
wehren tätig
vielen dank damit ist dieser antrag
angenommen bei zustimmung durch die
fraktion die linke der spd bündnis 90
die grünen und der fdp dagegen hat
gestimmt die fraktion der cdu/csu die
fraktion der afg hat sich enthalten